hello and welcome to this video I'm
playing Java these are body Java DISA
body
yeah the exchange variation of the
alicorns very quick Bishop f6
and now I think I have to go be three
I keep forgetting move orders in this
line or Age 3 it's both ok
now they play d5 and in this position
that's unusual actually it's far more
common to put it on C aid in order to
reroute to a5 later anyhow let's see how
to play this I going to go before for
sure it maybe move the rook first yeah
not quite sure way I'm so let's just go
before
okay now a4 a5 b5 night before bishop be
one that's Knight takes e5 this is some
this is a funny tactical motif that is
worth knowing
okay that is sister grouping interesting
it's to put this to e6
we are very interesting in the night on
before is some it's looking it looks
like a good piece but it's not good
really really sure that this is actually
the case so going to what to do first
here actually ninety three to five maybe
ninety six is a surprising move not
entirely sure what this is doing and
where it wants to go you kind of know
what he six is supposed to do here put
pressure on deform but the 90s some it's
a little bit unclear what this does my
plane here is supply route C e1 and then
f4 Knight age five to attack on the
kingside while the night on before is
stuck let's um let's say the standard
kind of plane in this situation so let's
go here the night goes back to e7 and
not entirely sure what this what this is
supposed to lead to at the end
okay this I did not think about it's not
such a bad move oh really
okay so Michael back but probably
chicken yeah well if he takes rook takes
he cannot play rook e8 which is super
important okay b6 yeah it's so difficult
to play Knight a success a five is
always under fire
okay now g4 on g4 g 4h three rupee five
it's all pretty strong yeah here even
even f5 immediately as a move
it's not time
if it takes at Queen g5 that's too
dangerous
I don't think okay tending Bishop b5
I don't quite believe it so let's just
take this thing take this thing my King
has a bit open so I have to check that I
don't fall into some some silly trick
here there's a chick
I would have liked to play more active
move somehow it
getting be sin shall do the trick
okay so yeah this was an interesting
game for sure yeah this is a theoretical
position for sure and here I think age
three is what I had in the book Queen d2
is also okay it is not a huge difference
in quality at all yeah here normally 9ca
displayed but the way he played it it
made quite a lot of sense actually put
the knight on to e6 he never went there
but that was the what was the thing yeah
he it's it's important not a form
yeah because a5 b5 night before and now
you cannot preserve this bishop and you
would like to do so because the bishop
on b1 would dominate this night as we
saw in the game here this doesn't work
though because this is hanging so I knew
this idea and move the rook first and
only then push it further yeah now a5
I'm really not certain that this is
helping black 96's maybe maybe better a5
b5 and now again this is a dominated
piece and I feel I feel white has some
advantage but he now played a couple of
autumn louvers 96 back and this was this
was odd you know when f4 night h5 seems
to be stronger even but it cannot be
really bad yeah it's important here that
he cannot just do this because at the
end f5 is dropping like this must be 6
g6 yeah now forward and I think f5 is
strong yeah it is strong because what he
did
taking I think he cannot play and then
this must be right it opens up it opens
up everything
the bishop can enter Bishop to e5 and so
on it looks good and that dead I don't
feel short work king h1 okay miss might
move bad no it also wins yeah I I didn't
really calculate this winning but it
just looks fantastic Bishop e5 is such a
strong threat of success may be one of
the better tries and okay this is this
doesn't work yeah yeah that was the
pretty good demonstration what why this
after in this line does get as much
space and possible and try to suffocate
black thanks a lot for watching